Pete where are you hey how you doing
good
I'm in Cooperstown of course and last
night I had an appearance at Rochester
for their triple-a team which is a
triple-a team of Minnesota and I flew
back in here last night and be here for
the weekend signing autographs today
with Steve Garvey and tomorrow with Tony
Perez and Andre Dawson and Ken Griffey
senior and Saturday the same and honey
go back to Vegas and we're excited about
fan D action I know we're having a pic
10 contest this weekend starting tonight
at 7 in a way of work standards you can
pick eight players and two pitchers and
the winners the 25 winners will go a
Monday for the championship and the
champion get to come to Vegas airfare
included for a two nights stand and
dinner with Pete Rose out there so it's
it's a lot of fun you know you can play
for free or you can play for money in
the space it allowed money games but
we're very excited about the opportunity
to create guys to follow the game more
and that's what happens when you have
fast eSports as you know now do you have
to run this by baseball at all do you
care what their opinion is not really
because they're ten percent owners of
draftkings yeah and the Commissioner and
the Commissioner a number of times is
that the fantasy sports it's not
gambling so you know I'm I'm playing
right up their alley and there again Dan
I'm in a situation now I don't I did
have to have permission last night to go
on the field just like I had to have
permission when I got my Hall of Fame
induction last week and Cincinnati and I
they had permission the next day and
they retired my number but this is kind
of interesting if you wanna know the
truth last night you know one that
wasn't one of the big things I enjoy
when I go to a a minor league appearance
is going in the clubhouse and talking
with the players and
you know explaining them how hard it is
to make the big leagues and what the
rewards are after you make the big
leagues and when I got there last night
I guess the Commissioner that League
told the you know the Rochester people
that I wasn't allowed to go in the
clubhouse and I wasn't allowed to shake
hands or talk to the players and I
wasn't allowed to shake or talk to the
umpires well so figure that out so you
know I mean I said no Pete I don't know
I I don't know because like I said mr.
Manfred has been he's really loosened
arranged around my neck I mean he's
allowed me to feel this year at the
all-star game for this franchise for he
has the blessings of me working on Fox
he allowed me on a field last week in
Cincinnati all three days so I don't
know if the Commissioner the
Commissioner of the league got scared of
what it was but one of the big things
about it appearances you could imagine
an assist going in there and talking to
these young kids who bitin it to bit to
make the big leagues because I can do
nothing but help them and relax them and
tell me how hard it is to get there and
what it's worth once you get there so
but that's something's happened last
night we're worrying more about what's
going to go on in the future yeah but I
don't know like what what do they think
you're going to do or say to these kids
I don't understand this but but you
nobody gave you a reason why you weren't
allowed to be on the field or you
weren't allowed to talk to umpires I
even asked a gentleman last night them
with many for the first time Dan was the
same great guy I said I said Dan I said
could you tell me who said I couldn't go
in the clubhouse and he thought for a
minute he said it was our commissioner
and I don't know if he got word from the
commissioner's office how good things I
would think not
because mr. Manfred has been very
cordial toward me you know he he rolled
on my situation which I disagreed with
but that he's the boss and you know I
have I'm not gonna sit here and badmouth
anybody I just thought that was kind of
unusual that they can they can try to
use you to fill the stadium up but yet
you can't go into Clubhouse and and tall
to the players and I can do it in
independently teams because they're not
affiliated filling a major you know then
I do it all the time but and they always
seem to enjoy asking me questions about
the great game of baseball ace Petros
seventeen time all-star you made the
all-star game at five different
positions Pete yeah I made it first
second third left and right as any
nobody I find a spot where I could play
rather so I could get my hat back you
remember your last at-bat in baseball
I'm sure you do yes well man do I was 45
years old and I tried to pinch it off
the goose Gossage yeah walking good
answer missing you later not for me I
got to get out of here so I you know Dan
I never did retire I just quit playing
in August of 86 yeah because at that
time I was letting Tony Perez play
against the left-hander's because he was
chasing the Latino homerun championship
which he ended up getting but it's been
- since he retired but you know we were
we were the best of friends we still
aren't the next they had that before
that was against San Diego - and Lance
McCullers struck me out so I convinced
myself that 45 years old is not the age
to be tensioned against these bullet
throwers who was the hardest thrower you
faced probably junior Richard oh yeah
you know he threw a 99 mount hour
fastball at 93 mile an hour
slider Ryan Darren from the Yankees that
played for the Phillies threw hard Nolan
Ryan threw hard we had a lot of guys
that threw hard but the best they got to
give me the most trouble whatever Dan
was was a gentleman by the name of Sandy
Koufax but you gotta remember my first
three years in the league 63 four and
five he struck out over a thousand so
why wasn't the only one he was getting
out yeah he was good yeah he was pretty
good yeah yeah yeah I got 10 457 off him
so don't get your calculators out and
that's 170 when you don't hit your
weight off of a guy you can't talk to
Pete Rose joining us Dan Patrick show
tell me if the quotes correct you don't
think David Ortiz Big Papi is a
hall-of-famer no no I said I said yeah
he's a hall-of-famer just based on his
postseason career but I'd like to see
him get some more hits I'd like to see
for 2,400 hits and it's Dan I was
talking to someone the other day I don't
know how you feel about this but this
guy's in the MVP voting isn't he yeah if
you ever heard of an MVP retiring no I
just don't think he's going to retire I
just unless he hates the game because it
seems to me watching him on the field on
a nightly basis he loves the fans he
loves his teammates he loves the Red Sox
and he loves to play baseball I don't
know what to I sing about retiring cuz
he can still play at a top level I think
that he said it's the way he said his
body was kind of banged up that he was
just he was tired his ankles his feet so
should you be an MVP candidate if you
don't play in the field yeah if you
produce offensively because there's not
too many MVP candidates you worry about
their defense
you know laws you just don't embarrass
themselves you know there's not too many
guys to make the Hall of Fame based on
their their glove sure you can talk
about Ozzie Smith and people I get it 15
16 17 Gold Gloves
but David or David Ortiz is a hitter you
know he's a hitter and he's a he's a run
producer and I want to be surprised I
think Boston's ahead now they fairly
caught Baltimore that's another thing
what else bigger the play oh the World
Series
you're going to be the MVP and win a
World Series and say see you later
alligator my feet hurt he makes that
money he can buy defeat would you rather
buy do I did yeah I don't wanna retire
because I like to watch you play I think
when you when you like to watch somebody
play you want to play as always a
possibly kid I guess I'm different
the only guy I can think of it went out
on top and you probably know more but
that's just to me what
Elway yeah but he was banged up he was
banged up yeah a Jim Brown Jim Brown
yeah Jim Brown went out on top
well Jimmy that was in the 50s I mean it
take a guy like Derek Jeter Derek Jeter
didn't go out on top
Rivera man a pitcher for the Yankees the
relief pitcher he did go out on top so I
just think that guys that are still
enjoying themselves and playing at a top
level
have a hard time retirement I guess
David Ortiz was one of those different
guys because once you start getting
these gifts all these ballparks you know
you think he wants to give that cowboy
hat back to Houston gave you on his last
trip down there would you rather be in
the Reds Hall of Fame or the baseball of
it well let me let me explain one thing
and I'm not taking anything away from
Cooperstown is this a wonderful place
and a lot of my buddies are down the
street I'm two blocks from Cooperstown
right now but there again they're both
important but the sister race Hall of
Fame was important to me dad because
actually I was born three miles from
where it's at and I rooted for the rest
my whole life I was a Cincinnati Reds
fan and they're going to their Hall of
Fame and I must tell you that the Reds
Hall of Fame is by far the best Hall of
Fame of the other 29 teams they put so
much effort in and so much they have so
many artifacts and so much history
because baseball started in Cincinnati
in 1869 first night be in 1935 and the
history that you can observe when you
just walk through that whole thing and
it you know it's just like getting my
number retired that was like 1 in 1a if
you're at the races and then next year
they're doing my statue so that would be
one B and I really can't tell you which
one is more important you know because
unless you go through something you
don't know what really the feelin is but
I had to goose-bumpy
days a couple weeks ago and Cincinnati
first for the Hall of Fame and next for
the number of retirement and of course
when you get a statue there's less
statues and numbers retire
there's no less numbers retired and guys
in the red Hall of Fame so I don't know
I don't know which one's more important
have you ever written one here the one
here in Cooperstown would be an ultimate
goal - no question about it because here
your your-your-your consider with the
greatest in the history of baseball but
in Cincinnati you know I'm on the I'm in
the Hall of Fame with the greatest
catcher in the history of baseball in
the greatest second base in the history
of baseball so we've got some great
situations back there in Cincinnati -
have you ever written a Hall of Fame
speech for Cooperstown now I've never
written a speech any time I can't read
off of a piece of paper because I'm
embarrassed to put my classes on if I
don't I can't see the pieces that's why
I'm glad I'm sitting here talking to you
on the speakerphone because I got my
glasses on with my nose rub I'm bad with
a prompter a Pete good luck with a fan D
action it's FA n - D - action.com daily
fantasy sports site and you can go pick
against Pete Pete's pics giving an
opportunity to challenge him on a daily
basis have fun this weekend in
Cooperstown and nice catching up with
you Pete it's always a pleasure totally
but you know what you're doing thank you
have a great day all right that's Pete
Rose the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience